[Music]
well a few months ago James d'amour
learned the hard way what happens when
you question the groupthink of Silicon
Valley while working at Google the
world's most powerful company do more
privately circulated a paper questioning
his employers diversity policies he
didn't attack anyone he just questioned
the internal logic of what he was being
told for that the company vilified him
and his character and then fired him now
do more and another X Google employee
David Reutimann are suing that company
they're accusing Google of systemic bias
against white employees men and
conservatives their 161 page lawsuit
exposes a remarkable and terrifying
climate at Google
a place where biased hateful and even
violent political rhetoric is totally
acceptable just as long as it's directed
against the right targets the suit
contains documents that shows Googlers
openly maintained for example
politically motivated employee black
lists here's one in 2015 Google manager
Paul Cowen wrote the following on
Google's internal networks for all
employees to see if you express a
dunderheaded opinion about religion
about politics or about social justice
it turns out I'm allowed to think you're
a half-wit I'm perfectly within my
rights to mentally categorize you in my
D head box yes I maintained mentally but
not yet publicly a blacklist if I had to
work with people on this list I would
refuse and try to get them removed the
black lists were real and not just
internal they also applied to
conservative figures from outside the
company bloggers Curtis Garvin known
online is mensches mold bug once visited
Google to have lunch with an employee
according to the suit yarv ins arrival
triggered a silent alarm at Google
security arrived to escort him off
campus his mere presence was considered
unacceptable
according to lawsuit Google employees
were awarded with bonuses by the company
for publicly denouncing d'amours memo in
April of 2017 Google manager Chris
Boselli advised employees if they spoke
at conferences they should do so only
while demanding that white males from
other companies be kicked off panels in
favor of women or non-white employees
quote you'll feel
damn smug about doing it Bozell said
google HR said boo sells attacks on the
basis of race and gender somehow broke
no company rules and that's just
scratching the surface of what d'amour
has brought to light the suit has more
than a hundred examples of employees and
managers saying conservatives or Trump
supporters ought to be fired defending
political violence implementing quota
systems to discriminate against white
people and men to the benefit of other
favored groups it's intense it's
appalling but don't kid yourself it's
not just happening at Google last night
Dennis Finley was an editor at the
Burlington Free Press was fired by the
media giant Gannett because he dared to
question just question a proposal that
would add a third gender option to
driver's licenses in Vermont now if
you're conservative it might be
difficult to get your head around what
is happening in this country so much has
changed but here's the bottom line the
federal government is no longer the main
threat to your privacy and to your
freedoms you've grown up thinking that
it's no longer true big corporations are
the main threat to your freedom and your
privacy the government doesn't own your
private emails Google does federal
employees can't be fired for their
political views private sector employees
are all the time the Trump
administration can't end your ability to
publicly communicate your ideas Twitter
and Facebook can do that and they do do
it all the time the Orwellian future is
increasingly the Orwellian present and
tech barons are becoming our new comma
czars liberals who once admirably stood
up for free expression in an opposition
to concentrations of corporate power
have been thoroughly co-opted they're
getting rich from it James d'amour has
seen it all from the inside firsthand he
joins us now with his lawyer Harmeet
Dylan welcome to you both happy to be
here
so James in reading these documents
what's so striking is not just that you
got fired for expressing your views and
I want to restate having read the piece
that got you fired
you weren't attacking anybody but you're
raising questions you get fired for that
but google seemed to feel the need to
vilify you after you got fired to
discredit you to attack your character
and to encourage others to do the same
that seems Stalinist why did they feel
the need to do that do you think because
I attacked their orthodoxy and they
really need to send a message to other
employees that no you can't do this you
can't question our policies yeah well
they certainly did paying bonuses to
people who denounced you like a camera
ruse education session so Harmeet in
this complaint you have example after
example of google targeting people on
the basis of their race and their sex my
impression was that was illegal is it it
is illegal it's illegal under federal
law it's illegal under California law
and what a lot of lawyers even around
the country don't understand that under
California law we have a unique Labor
Code provision that makes it illegal to
discriminate against somebody on the
basis of their political activities or
their political views so that is among
the claims in our lawsuit and that can
actually affect a lot and it has
affected women at Google so to be clear
our lawsuit actually includes women as
well if they've been discriminated
against on the basis of any of these
protected characteristics but I mean
Google is you know it is the most
powerful company in the world the most
famous company in the world and they're
doing this openly I mean on internal
servers they don't seem to have worried
they're gonna get in trouble for
violating a pretty basic law why well so
there are 700 billion dollar-plus
company they are ubiquitous they have
virtual monopoly power over search
engines and they've been getting away
with it for a long time now you know
probably you and I and some other
conservatives have been alarmed about
what we've read about Google being able
to scan Gmail and keep all of your data
that's what's really troubling about
this they at one time know everything
about you and at the other hand they're
using that information against you we've
seen them do this in their commercial
practices as well the D monetization of
viewpoints they don't believe in on
YouTube and other places and I'm hearing
from people inside the company and
people who've left the company that
their artificial intelligence programs
for search engines similarly are
applying political biases and filters
and you and I wouldn't even know it and
eventually we're going to find that
they're controlling what people think
they are obviously inside the
Bini they're getting away with punishing
people and controlling what people think
and you know people don't understand
that on Silicon Valley they have these
campuses and you come to the campus in
the morning they take care of your dry
cleaning all of your meals entertainment
everything and so people are in this
little bubble it's like the brave new
world really can value it's and that's
fine but the fact that they're
controlling our political dialogue and
the way people experience reality and
Congress just sits there passively is if
they have no authority is is
contemptible so James I would encourage
by the way our viewers to go online and
read what you wrote because it's hardly
radical it's sensible and smart do you
think that being at odds with Google is
going to affect your future employment
prospects yes definitely and many
employees have made it clear that
they're spreading the message about not
only me but anyone that they've
discovered that has certain viewpoints
to blackball them out of careers within
Silicon Valley so why is that not
terrifying
I think it is yeah where every James
d'amore who got fired Tucker there are
many people inside the company who we
represent who are afraid to even raise
their hand and say this is happening to
me because the threat is not just of a
blacklist within Google but of a
blacklist within the entire tech
community throughout the United States
that's that's how scary this is if
you're a conservative and you grew up
thinking that the federal bureaucracy
was the greatest threat to you it takes
a while to realize no it's not actually
it's Google and they have more power and
I just got speed to you both and we
really wish you well we'll be following
this case thanks a lot for coming on
Thank You Tucker
thank you